- hello this is your host ethan klein of
the h-street podcast experience live
formerly live the name is ashley podcast
experience formerly live nice or no it
should be formally live as the HD
podcast experience ELA my beautiful
co-host having a good hair day today
thank you you says you think you look
bad I do over here you were you are
having a bomb err day dude I saw myself
for a brief second and I let go must be
hard to be like actually attractive
because you have some expectation for
yourself me when I see myself and I have
no expectation and I and I have no
judgment because it's always bad because
like not all I'm attractive person I
expected to look like kind of good when
I see myself so I'm rock bottom and I
expect only the worst so I'd I'm not you
know rock bottom trust me baby you are
not you got enough I got you yeah eight
nothing fazes me okay that's good TGIF
thank God it's Friday
oh I love Friday I got to spend some
time with Theodore I get to not sleep I
get to just hang out you know hmm
love the weekends oh we're getting a new
dog too yeah Tuesday a little white yogi
your key that we my mom sent us a
picture of this guy from the animal
shelter and we drove an hour and a half
to go to go rescue him and he's this
sweet sweet little thing sweet little
white Yorkie just shred her size in his
age and so on Tuesday we're gonna go
pick him up and bring him home he's a
white Yorkie - never named so we're
calling him Alfredo come on thank you -
door - and quit for sponsoring this
episode also on Tuesday of next week
we're having Mick West coming on
he's a skeptical investigator that
investigates and debunks conspiracy
theories very excited actually I think
that's right down my alley
I'd like to hear what he has to say
about a lot of things Epstein
at the for most of it I got asking about
the to puck its to puck a lot yeah why
not he's like no I'm like all right well
this interview is over
get out you know can you put up a thread
dan for people to leave questions for
him on the credit sure thank you
um so that's I'm looking for to that on
Tuesday we're gonna be getting the
scooter next week the Gatsby the Great
Gatsby
I'm gonna be looking forward to that now
we reported on World of Warcraft classic
coming back last week and I was very
excited to try it out I was like you
know everyone's playing it's gonna be
fun they gave it this vibrant community
so me and ela both download the game and
I was proud of myself because I was very
open-minded you were very open-minded
that is not my [ __ ] at all this mother
game you're too open-minded it scared me
because I see the wow-wow claims every
soul people like you are exactly who Wow
get perfect mother exactly cuz you're
like I'm just gonna try them open mind I
never played video games and then all of
a sudden you're like a 90 level of level
90 rating yeah and I never see you again
so we got it then we made characters by
the way all the female characters suck
yeah they're really boring
I cannot stand how females are in the
end video games like like a
twelve-year-old kid's fantasy is this
gamergate I didn't think I would go
there but I'm kind of there just surely
cannot stand female characters in video
games I really can't it's not that they
were all sexy looking but they were just
really boring it's not that sexy looking
but they are yeah there's always like oh
please they barely wear anything above
the booze that's normal it's like a
Undead that's just how we dress yeah
that's how one we dress that's how they
should dress I think there's like these
undead zombie characters their jaws are
falling off their decap they're
decomposing and before you but they love
fat luscious titties so that was the
character that I wanted
and then you look at the male character
and they look so cool yeah they're like
scary and cool okay oh yeah a female
just boobs titties are you discount the
coolness of titties though titties come
for a lot
I picked the male character isn't
wanting us to be male and female I was
like sorry we're gonna be two males
that's I can't do it it's fun but you
know and fit in these games the females
a lot of dudes will play females and
pretend to be female so that they can
get free [ __ ] from all the N cells on
Wow
so there's there's character I made his
female oh really
yeah then does she have fat titties yeah
she she does not have fat titties as far
as I could tell no I actually I think I
mean of course you're you're entitled to
feel that way I actually think the
female models in that game look a lot
better than the male ones like the male
ones look my Waring no no there's no
that's a dump Nova Breaking Away okay
that since I refute that in its entirety
so how long do you play for okay so we
both so I knew that there was a free
trial and so I go to play classic and
they're like oh you need to buy the game
I was like of course Blizzard so we buy
we activate two accounts we strop 30
bucks and where we both picked Aaron and
we're going and we're killing some
quails not boars in Thunder Bluff it's
like feather quails some kind of ostrich
looking thing we do one quest and I'm
getting so anxious because I'm having
flashbacks I'm having sweat I'm like
dude I have [ __ ] to do I'm trying to run
a business I'm trying to run a podcast
you know and I'm seeing ela they're all
open-minded and playing and she's
starting to have fun a little bit and
I'm like I can't do this I cannot do
this
I started getting super anxious it did
and I was not I didn't know someone was
going on like I'm I thought I wasn't
gonna like it and I was kind of enjoying
it by you we're looking like you just
saw the devil because yeah I did because
first of all you were open-minded and
enjoying it and then I was just seeing
our last
we just had a kid we're trying to work
I'm telling you you there's not there's
not space in her life for world of
warcraft right now and there was a new
episode of bachelor in paradise and I'm
like we're not watching bachelor in
paradise I don't know it just didn't
feel right I and Elia raise a good point
when we're 60 years old and retired that
was what I said then we can set up a
gaming den for the two of us yeah but
those days are behind I I wish I knew
you during those days I can't do that
anymore
mm-hm I can play console games really
casual games mmo's that's not my mo so
and did you get to play yeah I've been
playing oh you didn't yeah
does it make you anxious no but I don't
have a child so the job the cat every
dog ohshe redder
oh yeah shredder so sad he couldn't
stand us playing looks like what is
wrong with you guys what are you doing
he wants to play all the time and he's
bored him and then me and Neil are
sitting at the table just staring at our
laptops anyway what's going on here I'm
everything in the universe is calling me
where I saw myself lighting up like a
like a crack pipe or smoking crystal
meth or something and I like hit at once
and I was like Oh baby I'm gonna enjoy
this too much
we're like about to shoot up heroin I
was like oh mama this feels too good
yeah I haven't seen you that anxious and
I don't know I don't even know when
you've been that anxious I can do it I
wish I could there'll be a day some day
the kids go off to college we're retired
and then it's like don't call me between
these hours Theodore your mom are raving
you're looking forward to that that
would be great and then it's just like
pizza and cart disease you know what I'm
saying high cholesterol lipitor yeah
that's a dream doctor visits in a while
just like tons of pills you know AARP
what's that sack
are it's like you can apply for that
when you're 65 yeah
Arpi mmm look I have so much to look
forward to that's like old old [ __ ]
when you get your pension from the
government sure yeah
fast forward I'd like to skip the next
38 years of my life is you ever feel
like that you're like can I just go into
a coma for 30 years
mm-hmm just waste the best years of my
life skip to the end are you gonna ride
the Gatsby yeah dude
come on you think I'm gonna be driving
in a car gonna be like 400 pounds of
I've lost a leg to diabetes all right
let's move on okay so anyway Wow I tried
it can do it but here's something that I
think I could do we've talked about
World Records on the show before and we
hold them in high regard these our
athletes these are accomplished people
they've achieved what no other human
could achieve the Guinness World Records
huh it's like such a coveted title and
so when I came across this the lean mean
Mayo machine Michelle let's go Bree
breaks the world record for eating the
most Mayo in a minute and I mean this is
the best of the best people here there's
a little biopic about her even being as
that it's just such an epic adventure
that I thought we could watch together
so feast your eyes oh we're gonna get
flamed hello can you [ __ ] waltz on
you yeah I called it that we can't do
this get out of here let's get to the
mail so she has a spirit it's spaghetti
oh there's no sound
turn it down oh you did that let's see
if there's music here okay
yeah there's kind of like hardcore metal
so you can turn the music off but let's
let's see her devour this bowl of
spaghetti it's so crazy it's like she
just put stuff in there in her mouth and
it disappeared like this there's no
garbage Mosel that's pretty impressive
actually
maybe she's hungry there's a little
sauce in the corner there the dudes like
ellos [ __ ] sauce you believe that
these guys 28 seconds we're so proud of
you Michele here she is with her jars of
mayonnaise so we're measuring she does
hot dogs first before the mayonnaise oh
that's exciting and on the first try she
doesn't break the record but then she
gets to get three tries Oh for real yeah
on the second one she does so fastest
hot dog in the game here tried it let's
get some volume quickly just dead but up
dropping traffic on it yeah we go oh no
hands why do I know her like I'm saying
these records are just so it's like
fastest hot dog fastest hot dog with no
of hands fastest hot dog under a minute
no these are records that already exist
and she's breaking them like no hands I
mean who [ __ ] like so she kind of
took too long oh yeah that was a week I
feel like I could eat I could beat that
record do you see how she doesn't
thought there's no chewing no nothing
hmm just kind of inhales yeah that one
yeah he's got like a gene mutation that
she's putting to the best use possible
okay there there's some hotly debated
words being exchanged between the judge
and contestants oh here she goes this is
the world record guys so don't blink I
love how she's sitting there with three
jars of mayonnaise okay there you go
yeah well incredible really what it what
an athlete what an athlete but enough
with the [ __ ] let's get to the main
show you know this is the real show yeah
hit me with the volume so the record
she's going for is the most mayonnaise
start with your hands lie on the table
as I have best walk 3 Zack this is you
two days ago go horsey sauce say horsey
okay she's got a huge spoon right each
serving spoon
I love ma'am that might of course you do
yeah no you don't you said you love
horsey sauce and you guys getting three
package
why was the Arby's dude she is [ __ ]
eating she just ate a whole jar man I'm
nauseous
I can't watch
man is the new word thing because by
itself it's so putrid on a sandwich it's
the best thing ever
yeah yeah but also too much mayonnaise
on the sandwich I like I gotta throw it
out dude she loves mayonnaise look at
her go oh god why bad is why could it be
this world she's a champion she's a true
athlete
I don't think sure nice couldn't do what
she does no she's an athlete sure nice
is a entertainer she's an athlete
there's a difference love how tensed
look at that look at the UH look at the
judge she's not she's not a
gagging no pitcher she's not she can't
look away how do you even find out that
you're good at this you know I mean is
that even a record that you would be
proud to hold like I would try to lose
no you wouldn't that get it do weaves
manage good set all right all right all
right back we got the semantics I'm
serious let's set it up do we have
Manny's in the fridge danly I don't know
and gonna taste it anyway aged man
Miracle Whip Mayo she had to slow down
man yeah she does slow down
she's still got a quite a pace I'm so
sick right now this is so [ __ ]
disgusting you nasty nasty girl put
those skills to better use I don't know
what not this
not this to see how it just goes in her
mouth and gone Zakhar you turned on that
all or what's you turned on I'm kind of
hungry though I don't believe you
you just want airtime dude no but I'll
put you I mean I'd like to watch that
regardless she's getting full guys what
happens to your buddy
cuz I'm somewhat imagine what if any
[ __ ] looks like it's got to be diarrhea
there's no way your body can process oh
my god she goes I'm getting full she ate
too fast she's got some common color is
is not - god no a hundred thousand I
mean I don't know like it's a very she's
slow down yeah okay yeah you can stop
now
pink oh you're telling her got her she's
your good that puke would look like oh
this is like the worst I've ever seen
just the weirdest porn you've ever seen
idols and I'm among them I think it's
gonna be super exciting well guys here
we go she's punching the number all my
friends for Christmas but don't tell
them why did this look like it was shot
in like a conference hall of the holiday
inn so get oh this is so porn like oh
well it's very porn like the since the
Scituate but I was kind of impressed
with the channel they have it like this
video they have it about other gayness
holders
dude this is underground - there's only
50,000 views like I want to know what's
what else is on that channel hmm we're
doing our research we're gonna find some
other good [ __ ]
there checked out at a motel they set up
a table looking at the curtain probably
because there's like cheap decorations
all over the curtain was the only like
blink shot this is a pornography this is
a Mayo eating pork but this is so much
better than just reading about it in the
book
don't you think
there's nothing to do this justice it'd
make me gag on one point though damn do
we have Mayo in the fridge so we do I
don't know
can you postmates some big jarmail if
you can see this is some olive oil Mayo
no yeah I wouldn't do that to Zack I
feel like that's Zack what if we post my
tip will you eat it how big of a jar are
we talking well I mean you're backing
down what are you okay we'll get a big
jar you eat what you can yeah sure okay
let's get a lesser oh just one jar a big
well yeah I don't I don't I'm gonna be
real I don't think I could do I'm gonna
take three bites and like oh dude you
you you better finish that jar it's
gonna possible I could do one jar but I
don't think I could be [ __ ] ten of
them no no no you can do one - here's
the okay Zack we have to put something
on the line that post mites a jar of
mayo I'm working on it okay we got to
make it worth
Zacks wild we need to put about a prize
up for him if you can finish a jar of
mayonnaise what does he earn I'll tell
you right now if you help me I would if
you finish a whole jar of mayonnaise ACK
I'll give you five hundred dollars you
know I swear to god I'll give you five
hundred dollars if you finish a whole
jar of mayonnaise here today on this
show okay but you got to finish the
whole [ __ ] thing do it I'm not
[ __ ] around and I'm not gonna be
pitying you I'm not gonna give you like
pity money either I I wouldn't I
wouldn't do for the money I will just I
was just gonna do for the show love of
the game yeah but it's more excited I
don't want you you know what kind of jar
yeah well guys yeah this size this size
that's like you know the standard
standard yeah standard [ __ ] I'm excited
well we have got a spectacular end of
the show today
I love his willingness to get in there
for the show you know none of you
[ __ ] would eat mayonnaise nope dan
and Ian I'm surprised that then I'm
surprised that you're still so sensitive
after all the stuff we watch here that's
for Mayo in particular I don't know okay
just and I'm with you I like a little
bit of mayo on a sandwich you know
I don't hate mail but something about
just ask oh my god well maybe gag how do
you feel I've seen people eat sticks of
butter how do you feel about that I mean
that's bad it's not as bad okay Zack
you've got you know it's all I'm excited
I don't think you'll be able to do it I
think my money's safe okay but I
appreciate your valiant valiant training
you think you're gonna do it Zack I
don't know I'm gonna try okay well
Sophie if he vomits is that
disqualification yeah cuz you can't keep
you can't fall man if they vomit their
own yeah after they complete the
challenge they convolve if you vomit
during your let's follow the fear front
yeah if because the thing is once you
vomit you're done so if you've already
finished the jar you can vomit yeah
that's fine okay Zack deal good question
this is exciting 500 bucks it's a lot of
mail wait wait you got to watch how much
she broke the record [ __ ]
all right this is exciting who could
ever say that we don't push the envelope
here of a free podcast we're moving
we're moving we're jiving were slamming
do we have a big spoon like that Dan
I'll have to check I mean postmates just
say giant spoon let's see what we get
it's starving stuck with all the
Guinness world record titles and I'm
amongst them
I think it's gonna be super exciting
I'm gonna buy it even if it's for eating
mani for Christmas but don't tell them
because it's a surprise
Michelle today you attempted the record
for the most mayonnaise eaten in three
minutes
angle so to achieve this record you
needed to exceed a weight of 850 point
five grams okay in today's attempt you
consumed two thousand you guys I'm gonna
buy a Guinness Book for my kids to
surprise them for Christmas but don't
know him
imagine these kids trying to brag about
this at school my mom's in the Guinness
Book really Wow what for eating the most
mayonnaise in a minute well wow that's
kind of dope though is it hade you're
like yeah let me see that
I wonder if you bust that out for the
kids at home oh we got so much to get to
we got the mayonnaise dan let me know
when that's on the way you carry I'm
ordering I know Bradbury and raw we
trust so Ethan Bradberry is taking the
raw meme always elevating his game and
this new video blew me away he broke his
leg I don't know what happened he's in a
wheelchair and now he's like what Ian
described it as reception and I do think
that's a great describer cuz it's like
in a dream it's like two layers of
dreams and first of all he did the intro
at the beginning so that's pretty epic
now they took a lot of our ideas and
suggestions including the intro at the
beginning yeah
this is club man Letterman I do not
think we've never wash this whole thing
but I love the Bradbury out second intro
third intro
you totally click that
do you not smell fast-food and do do all
office of miles like fast food for
everyone do this here it's kind of
getting out of control so he's dreaming
now he's in no hospital and he's
dreaming that he's on a fork what is
this
what why my own awards gone for the
Oscar I really there's really no
explanation already get a hold of a
horse in the middle of buck in New York
City I mean that's reacting
is that legal to cruise around on a
horse in the city no no in the street
[Music]
there's no it's ah really don't get you
just don't get it what kind of thing
hey you don't trust in a rock
there you go who knows what you've been
come on we got a gun Ethan Bradberry
like trained enough to be riding a horse
in the city because horses can be kind
of unruly and they can run you kind of
got to know what you're doing but
apparently he he's qualified they could
kick someone the face of killing it's a
nightmare
apparently it's a nightmare hey hey oh
so wait this is a he's still in the
dream so I'm still dreaming and there's
a coffee shop with the raw this is
really just 12 minutes of abstract art
they're sniffing the raw on the counter
Bruno's ready to take a line of that man
oh they are doing it like it's cocaine
yeah
[Music]
what are they doing there at a
restaurant he's making it cool enough
for the coffee sir
ed you're marking a back oh my god this
is friends to do this [ __ ] like it
doesn't even make sense how do you even
explain it to them you know what because
they trust and Ron I don't gang baby in
the wheelchair he's still dreaming oh oh
oh
everyone turned him looking at Bradbury
that's that we're gonna go out
I got boon all to the front of me with
ammo and Johnny and I got a I love the
floors in one person damn pointed that
oh nice catch oh it's beautiful it's
really gonna watch this like five times
to catch over I really fit you know I'm
walking around the office and at home
and all the time forget about it
oh yeah get in huh and I really think
that Ethan Bradberry is somewhat of a
creative genius but he's one tamed much
like like a horse if I can say you're a
wild horse and if he could just package
his ideas better or maybe convey a
little more clarity I think that there
could be something special there but
what we have here is 13 minutes of pure
Rob Robert it's pure raw we need refine
baby we need some cream and sugar in
this and eat poor souls in one body
[Applause]
not actually happening guys listen to me
carefully arms I want you hanging around
Johnny my mother called me the other day
he tells me she's seen you again
tap-dancing on a beefcake on at a
Verrazano Bridge forget about dancing
all right cake what does that mean under
the bear is on a bridge cuz I'm in gay
tap dancing with a beefcake under the
bridge
what could that possibly mean
and he's confronting him he did
something wrong right he's doing a
godfather thing where he's looking over
the city and he's got to do a hit on
somebody you know nobody out here ever
that's mine
yeah that's they focus on this mission
in the heart of Brooklyn true the New
York City for a run I love you I got
activity Shh
and we get it going God please that stop
everyone goes crazy I mean the there's
in his mind I feel like there's a
narrative I know and I can that's really
what is it it's unbelievable and he went
through all the effort to all the world
would make this happen a bad dream I
smoked Taco Bell we need the men
spreading camera I'll rather break them
so here's the idea we pitched it we can
wrap it up here they brought the
generator so last time we were saying
like they were carrying a coffee machine
with them and it wasn't plugged doing it
you didn't even do it by the time they
got to their wash off the raw was called
so so we recognize the power generator I
think you deliberate they got this huge
power generator gas powered so that they
can have it raw in the middle
now they go into coffee shop and they
start doing that with the generator they
really yeah that's fantastic
this is quality vodka oh we got a little
subliminal message yeah
Vikram si are we gonna go the subliminal
[ __ ] he says here you guys go feast your
eyes on the mind of Brad berry I'm
seeing fingers everywhere but none of
them are slamming curricula may we all
get together someday in the perfect
world and slammed a regula raw ritual
with great essence your good old folk
Ethan Bradberry yeah I think he's really
happy that we're dissecting this like
Citizen Kane you know we don't know the
frame I don't think he'd bring today oh
he does
I feel like they don't realize it's
funny like the generator I don't like I
feel like they don't realize that it's
funny because they they gotta like make
it but that's what's funny isn't it when
they don't realize what's funny I just I
want people to watch this video I'm not
sure how to help them cuz right now it
only has five thousand views I think I
should cheer admit it a video for him
yeah I think it needs to be his idea he
mishit tell me was creative vision tell
me the story and all of you and tell the
story you know I usually like the raw
father like he's the godmother but he's
the raw father and so I think there's a
collaboration here the raw father and -
would that be so I picked the postman on
her main channel I don't know though
it's a big commitment mm-hmm anonymous
could as committed to him as he is we
got to take a break going on too long
how long has it been
can we just watch the pot in the shop I
was 32 we're two minutes over break them
so okay here they are okay watch watch
this shot epic why is he wearing of
their little brother is wearing the
plane pillow
that's the new height piece yeah so okay
nice shot Dennis Dennis social off that
I'm okay yeah let's take a break don't
rush to the depression I'm gonna run the
bathroom and a quick break we're gonna
keep staying in the raw
today we are sponsored by door - and I'm
gonna give you a brief summary of this
offer to get you going five dollars off
your first order when you download the
door - app you use promo code h3 and you
got five dollars off your beautiful
restaurants that you love that's it baby
let's get eaten now here's the long
version
why cook oh they go they've got all this
[ __ ] Oh a long day tough day at school
don't have time no no why cook ever
that's a waste of time it's BS by the
time you got all the groceries and you
make the meals gonna cost you more
anyway that's why you need door - door -
connects you to your favorite restaurant
in your city ordering is easy you open
the app choose what you want to eat your
food will be delivered to you wherever
you are not only is your favorite pizza
joint already on door - but there are
over 340,000 restaurants in 3300 cities
so you might find a few new favorites as
well with door - door to door delivery
in over 50 states in Canada you can
order from your local go to Zoar choose
from your favorite national restaurants
like Chipotle Wendy's chick-fil-a I'm
gonna block that out Popeyes may be
right that and the Cheesecake Factory
don't worry about dinner let dinner come
to you with door - no let me tell you
one more time right now for our
listeners you get five dollars off your
first order for just of $15 or more so
was that clear five dollars off your
first order of $15 or more when you
download the door - app and enter promo
code HD that's five dollars for free
when you download the door - app from
the App Store and enter promo code h
sweet don't forget that's promo code
eight revive dollars off your first
freakin order from door -
your back to school your breath stinks
your mouth is disgusting nobody wants to
even look at you little don't get close
enough to you to smell your disgusting
breath does that sound all too familiar
well let me introduce you to quip get
quit calm /h three to dramatic or maybe
you just want clean teeth to
reel-to-reel I'll tell you what I owe
black look at this one and that's licked
you don't even see me brushing my teeth
in the dark let me tell you about quit
it's a vibrating tube it's powerful it's
soft it gets you clean in a way that no
other toothbrush can and it times you
out to make sure you're getting that
perfect then - dentist recommended brush
there's nothing like it on the market
that's why Oprah orgasmed when she said
oh she has got a thing called the owest
and she goes oh I love my vibrating tube
and also its multi-purpose you can put
it in your Oh Liss
but it's a olace no but it but primarily
it's good for the mouth other offices
you can explore on your own time
the quip is a toothbrush I swear to God
I don't use any other toothbrush their
bristles are so soft I have a problem
it's your gums don't grow back you do
not want to damage your gums this has
this really interesting rubbery soft
bristles that I've never felt another
toothbrush it doesn't harm my gums at
all head vibrates you're gonna get a
toothbrush like this that vibrates it's
gonna cost you 200 bucks
within these big name brands and a being
like the size of a battery okay this
thing vibrates it cleans your mouth it
what does it do it goes for three
minutes two minutes two minutes two
minutes and then every 30 seconds it
warns you to switch size maybe you're
getting a perfect brush it's dentist
recommended 25,000 dental professionals
it's accepted by the dental met American
Dental Association it's out of control
I love the quip it starts at just $25 so
if you want to see what it's like to
have a supreme brush supreme fresh
breath and supreme healthy guns
I recommend heading on over to get quick
calm slash h3 and get your first refill
pack for free it starts at just 25 bucks
I mean come on how
you you come on that's your first refill
pack for free g-e-t q UI p comm / h3 is
gonna be the best $25 you ever spent
I'm telling you you're gonna kiss you're
gonna cuddle it's gonna be clean you're
gonna love it
gobby sh forget about it and we're back
in the raw we're ready to rod up raw dog
it raw big inning ding ding rah
bra'tac euler know let's watch this is
just heating up and by the way this
isn't like starbucks this is some
artisan yeah you know big $10 coffee
yeah exactly
you see they bring the generator dude
that airplane pillow is such a flock in
the doorway oh yeah they brought it when
you see that or you're not gonna call
the FBI oh this is [ __ ] a fit and
there's just a bunch of hooligans I mean
the premise I just
for the nightmare why haven't I heard it
seems like a good dream something's
really dragging you here the generator
going so loud why do they look like
they're gonna trailer till like they're
all intimidating you don't have the
regular oh wait that sounds like me it's
coughing in the back you don't have the
regular oh that's totally hot that's me
bringing in the raw music so here we go
it's generated it's heated
yeah
[Music]
yes yes on one leg no love
he's so pumped up he doesn't even use
the crack baby this is a drill
[Applause]
they're not they don't laugh they just I
don't
oh yeah baby yeah yeah don't get that
wrong what are you on - hmm that's a
prank that's a prank in 2019 baby yeah
that's a big construction Frank right
[Applause]
that's a serious generator so now okay
now this is the reception like like he's
in the hospital so they go back to him
on the street but he's still in the
dream yeah you can tell by the shirt -
in the hospital he's got maybe this is a
metaphor - how lost he got in the meme
oh he's lost we're all lost he's not the
only one you can't wake up from the
night by the way his hair is so out of
control I feel like at one point his
hair was like stylish but now it's just
turned into this wild yeah wild untamed
look at his hair without five ounces
you can wake up you're having a
nightmare
epic a tango section for the ROI your
leg is broken
I want the rows of
your leg is broken you've been having a
nightmare for the past five blocks
they've got a bud I want the Royce and
you can
[Music]
that's a [ __ ] video what could you
say bad about that let's see um Ethan is
not getting enough recognition for these
vids well I agree that's my that's the
trouble I'm having right yeah can't wait
for Ethan and eager to react to this
well there's only 5,000 views so we got
it yeah it's really not cool I agree
5,000 it's not enough but yet it's not
there's no that doesn't even pay for the
generator they're losing money
it doesn't make I'm just saying to
anyone who's not on the show right now
it doesn't make any sense it's it's
totally on wastrel I mean it doesn't
even make sense to us really that's what
and I know there's a genius nuggie in
there that we have to undo mm-hmm so
Ethan I do salute you I do appreciate
what you're doing
oh they listen to you and bought the
generators there you go I love that
generator by the way yeah it was great
so keep that's a keeper keep doing your
thing you're clearly not making any
money from this they're losing yeah I
mean this isn't a this isn't a business
venture at this point they're just
providing us content podcast
how many did his other videos get that
we want reacted to let's check it's
always like fight like let's see if
there was 112 the regular schmegle of 55
these were all trailers so we're all
hyped up and now the big one came out
it's at 5,000 but we're gonna get this I
mean this one deserves to be seen yeah
oh thank you Dan
dude first of all I got a tip my beanie
to you who've turned the music down
right now well that was that Zach
everybody back there
good job that's what I'm talking thank
you that was genius
that was so great that I didn't have to
think about it I almost didn't even
realize that you guys I did that we're
at six seconds
Gold right well unless the cutoff five
we'll see though I will monitor down
real fast your talk I think we're good I
just think that is this just our friend
at it where did it bus this is this a
compliment isn't this like a way of kind
of goofing on someone and being like
doesn't matter he's embraced the meme
man I think I'll have props to Ethan
Bradberry honestly yeah yeah well he's
lost in the meme though he's embraced it
too far it's not - are these different
photos just or is it repeating it's
looping now
yeah it's loping ten minutes so that you
can't you come you can uh you don't have
to replay it every 30 seconds it's
enough to beat off - when out when I was
a kid the only porn we had was VHS tapes
and I remember once finding in my
brother's room I mean not not to you
know smear him or anything cuz I thought
it was brilliant when I found it and we
were young he would find he would find
the perfect time that like a nudie film
was on like Cinemax which is like HBO
but they show more raunchy stuff nothing
hardcore but like just a topless girl
and like a sex scene but it doesn't show
anything and he would film he would tape
it on the VHS and then he would
duplicate it so it was like the scene
would playback oh like six times in a
row so he could have like enough time to
be it off - it really it's not a hurry I
mean I would assume that's the only
reason why he would do it I haven't
talked to him ever about it but I found
it well I beat off - those tapes
I'm curious if he really did that of
course no he did it I'm telling you it
was totally engineered
Wow it was a VHS tape pretty creative
yeah I know I totally like good mother
you know necessities of mother of
ingenuity like playing yeah and here let
me what is going on with the smell am I
crazy
it's like coming and it's been slow
like a burger I was here Mexican food do
you guys smell that yeah you do
okay okay I thought you were I'm
smelling it all right we got to eat
we're all starving what do you want tell
Dan what you want I'm gonna go on the
next story just get me a regular
Swagelok all right yeah I mean surprise
sir
you guys order order that yeah I'm
starving I need food when the show ends
yeah one thing I want the veggie well
sure the impossible burger no with the
regular schmegle oh forget about it all
right you got it
I'll wait whatever then orient our
eating's interesting cuz they always go
a little more
they don't go flight they choose wisely
mmm I juice bluntly you choose like
you're gonna regret it
okay I'm thinking them that burger
sounds pretty good I don't know
there you go you don't for that what is
he in getting in what you want Far East
Far East Bowl how does that so don't get
a [ __ ] yeah well you're gonna regret
them getting the burger no the bowl was
bombed well you're getting a Far East
pool yes there must be Far East out of
your mind
all right get the Far East well you guys
don't know anything about living yeah
who's gonna say like right after you
finish your food I wish I didn't need
this I feel like I would say that how
could you say that about me
I think these are interesting and I'll
tell you why I don't shy away from
ordering food on the air and stuff like
this because it really offers a glimpse
behind the curtain as to what really
goes on and when these kinds of things
happen I think you assassinated I
thought that people were enjoying the
drama and the last food review and I'm
glad that they enjoyed it and surreal
it's all real told off as raw as it gets
rather than the Rost rawr than the roar
I'm excited I I'm happy people are
enjoying the food segments because I
don't want to stop and then we're not we
have some more planned but meanwhile Dan
go ahead and order that I'm gonna move
on
[Music]
hmm Zach's gonna be enjoying a little
appetizer before lunch arrives manis so
en did a little write-up on the cult of
Kanye Co he even got to the main stories
you know I'm already ready to [ __ ]
retire
TGIF baby all right let's talk about
this and go ahead and play her edit that
Kanye is building these levees said that
I'll start over yeah Kanye is starting a
cult he's building these huts on his
property and Hidden Hills without
permits he just started erecting them
inspired by Star Wars okay and his the
neighbors are complaining about noise
that he doesn't have a permit and the
city's saying you got to tear him down
basically or get a permit by the 15th of
September now we're gonna dig into this
yeah the clock is ticking but Ian's
prepared for us a little edit to set up
the segment so in without further ado
hit us with the regular schmegle Oh
[Music]
dinah water cure Ralph yeah remember you
remember how that girl in there the
people that was racing it but yeah she
was the good yes I will [ __ ] laser
you with alien [ __ ] eyes and explode
your [ __ ] head shut the [ __ ] try to
write a rap okay then you telling me
don't look at me like the [ __ ]
glitch you telling me people don't look
at Kanye West like the glitch right now
I am Warhol I am the number one most
impactful artist of our generation I am
Shakespeare in the flesh
well Disney Nike Google when someone
comes up and says something like I am a
god everybody says who does he think he
is I just told you what what happened
don't I will
what happened hmm what happened there I
don't know we just made glitch played it
all the way through before when someone
comes up as I just told you who I
thought I was Picasso is dead Steve Jobs
is dead what Disney is dead name
somebody liveth and she was on the side
of the video game the whole time it's in
my code I like some of the Gaga's songs
what the [ __ ] does she know about
cameras everybody wants to know what I
would do if I didn't win
[Music]
I guess we'll never know hey good
morning hey yourself you will believe in
yourself
I'm just the expresso I'm just a shot in
the morning to get you going to make you
believe that you could overcome that
situation that you're dealing with all
times
so and what did we just want that was a
watch so let me I won't comment it seems
almost to have land Punta Cana but I
know you're a true fan so were you
lampooning him a little bit or paying up
respect just goofing a little bit what
the you gotta be so bad my god let's
just curl it isn't fine go ahead Ian
sorry
sorry about that I'm getting goofed just
like kanye's that's how it goes yeah
just you know he's got some funny quotes
they all make sense you want to show
yourself when you're talking oh oh I'm
looking at your frame because you it's
showing you it's and hold the [ __ ]
phone here well you know yeah yeah um so
you you say you can explain all the
quotes so when he says do you think he's
the greatest gentle artist of our
generation I mean come on who are you
talking to forget about I come on I
guess in your life that might be true
well who would be your greatest artist
is it possible to say that artists are
losing their influence a little bit in
this day and age it's possible to say it
well his whole thing is saying there's
not like the icons that there were
that's why he says name somebody living
hmm
but he's saying I am that icon yeah but
certainly there's other well hooligans
who would you who's like you're big its
person they go wow that's inspiring
stuff
inspiring me hmm I liked I liked Paul
McCartney okay
you still crushing it well it's not his
music sucks these days to be honest but
still alive
so that's crushing it in my book but I
mean the Beatles is he says name someone
that's living Paul McCartney
I don't think Kanye can hold a candle to
Paul McCartney do you disagree with that
or agree with that Paul McCartney's been
around for you know a long time let's
see where Kanye's and John still around
needle you yeah I mean Paul McCartney
has co-signed him a Beatle
they made a album together it didn't
come out but Lou that'd be bad
unfortunately but about Elton John still
life he's an icon living so there's some
Jaden Smith let's take it easy there
yeah I just thought anyway let's get to
the to the domes we're really we're
really unfocused today ad h3h3 they see
what we call it our last dream that was
unfocusable I'm - I'm so scatterbrained
today because I'm just tired I'm just
I'm just tired you know I'm sleepy
literally and I'm starving I've been on
a diet and all I've been eating this
morning I had a small bowl of unflavored
oatmeal okay ever had a bull I have not
been on a diet what did I have for
breakfast this morning
okay yeah what are you already in for
lunch yeah I'm starving it's called a
diet what did I eat yesterday
Wienerschnitzel but I only have one dog
and fries and a huge bucket of fries
yeah it's called a diet you do the power
that food but anyway my plate of
vegetables this morning you didn't even
touch it I end up eating your vegetables
every morning the mood for sliced bell
pepper
Harry someone on a diet well it's more
calories at really okay
I had a bowl of unsweetened you're gonna
counter ever eaten a bowl of unsweetened
oatmeal okay water and oats okay but
you're gonna count the calories hard
boiled of cucumber I'm saying what is it
got to do with my dad then you order
french fries for lunch I'm not I'm you
brought it up like oh you well if you're
on a diet you should be eating a sliced
bell pepper in the morning and I'm
saying that it doesn't matter what's I
got to do with my diet but put it this
way you'll if I eat a bowl of oatmeal
and an egg maybe that's three four
hundred calories that's a light light
meal then the I agree I fully admit I'm
gonna I'm probably gonna eat a thousand
calories right now with the burger and
the French fries mm-hmm that puts me
still at 1,300 if I don't eat anything
for the rest of day maybe some fruit I'm
running a pretty good deficit still
maybe but that's not how you do it okay
you get hard this is in like two years
oh you think so why I'll eat some fruit
and then I mean it's not such a bad day
french fries french fries admittedly not
that I don't need french fries that
often this is a day this is a real yeah
I know I'm saying I know but I'm saying
guys this is real usually what you say
this is a real conversation
that's what's so special here that's
what makes this so special cameras here
or not this conversation would be the
same people who watch the highlights
miss out on this kind of old miss the
stuff in between that makes this podcast
great I think it's a shame that you
cannot commit to a diet I'm telling you
honestly I do I agree I'm because it's
first of all unhealthy you're at the
point of your life where you can make
attempt you can make a shift you can
either become a healthy adult or you're
gonna go like the fat sorry to say it
but like heart disease all this [ __ ]
that come with it adult like we there's
you can pick your Road so you're saying
French fries are out of the question
ever once a year once a year okay let's
start with once a month once a month
yeah that's a lot you really don't need
french fries
I don't eat french fries yeah I'm
working on it but I swear to god you
don't have you do not have the food
addiction that I have it's easy as an
addiction I I totally I know I
understand this problem I mean like he's
sucking on horsey sauce I understand
that it's an addiction but I'm just
saying that it's a shame that you don't
try a little harder to commit because
you'd like you did good for a week you
did really good for a week yeah I agree
you lost weight like a lot in one week
right I'm trying I am trying to figure
it out it's in my brain I don't think
this meal totally is gonna interrupt
anything I think it's part of a whole
big ecosystem I am sorting it out I'm
trying I am really trying okay I'm
trying I know you're disappointed in me
makes me but I'm ashamed of myself too
because I really do want to be at a
healthy way it's not that I'm
disappointed it's like I feel like I
want to help you because I feel like I
see the it's I see that it's an
addiction totally like I'm not I'm being
fully serious why I know I'm not
delusional about it I mean I'm not
delusional about it I'm fully aware but
I don't think publicly shaming me is
this is gonna help me am I on my
addiction was I ever considered getting
a like a personal trainer like somebody
I did work with me I did I didn't like
it okay
it's too weird also I don't trust her
advice she goes she tries putting me on
like the AK or like whatever he doe
she's like okay what you need to do is
go home and eat high fat ground beef
avocado sour cream and cheese just only
bread I'm like [ __ ] are you trying to
kill me
that's what I do I mean I'm sure I might
lose weight but I'm gonna [ __ ] I will
definitely die of heart disease that's
why I feel I'm scared for Joe Rogan man
I see what that [ __ ] eats I know
he's like breakfast time it's like steak
and like five eggs and a huge steak I
get like sick to go in there I'm scared
he works out like four hours a day it
doesn't matter you can't well sure yeah
they listen to me it doesn't matter
alright don't take advice from me don't
take Fitness advisor me Howard Stern has
a funny bit like how Oprah sells Weight
Watchers but she's fat as hell
he's like come take that advice from
this woman who's just always perpetually
fat he's like I should sell weight
nobody wants to take weight loss from a
skinny guy that's but the truth is
because Oprah's fat people people know
that she knows about their struggles
right someone like Howard or you god
forbid you don't know what it's like you
couldn't handle a day in my shoes okay
Eva is so like you seen the bite she
takes to these chicken sandwiches she
doesn't know what it's like to be me and
you sit there judge me I'm not judging
I'm not judging
I want me to at any size you know I know
you do I know you do you want me to be
healthy your intentions are pure I know
that I know but I think I'm figuring it
out I said like that you know my dad was
a skinny guy like his I know up until
his like thirties he was skinny yeah one
of the things your dad told me one of
the only things your dad ever
communicated with me was don't be don't
get fat like me he hated he would say
watch your weight it's uncomfortable
gives you all kinds of diseases
your dad was extraordin extraordinary
belly though yeah he had an
extraordinary belly
but in the end it's not you know what
got him mad but it doesn't know it
doesn't help it really doesn't like even
with cancer everything kind of factors
in right well they weren't weren't they
saying that he it was good that he had
so much because he was losing so much
weight from chemo that it's good he had
that stars I'm trying to find to give
myself a silver lining here anyway
rest in peace your dad obviously I prom
I'm I'm always thinking about it and I'm
strategizing and I know you're gonna see
you're gonna get inspired someday I'm
gonna make a fouseytube esque weight
loss video that's gonna blow you all
away I was gonna say I mean maybe you
need to power this with the mean we need
to make this like a thing on the podcast
I mean I've always wanted to have a
jacked Ethan yeah like him it would
honestly be hilarious if you got [ __ ]
ripped so I don't think but I'll get
I'll get skinny
yo spouting doubt 100 I don't I don't
want you to think that I want you to get
ripped or anything I know you don't I
know you don't you just want me to be
healthy yeah but you boy you don't know
is healthy at every size is everyone
gonna hate me do I seem now like I mean
oh yeah people are gonna be pissed about
this angle but I want them to know I'm
just being real I can see ya I'm like
Ely I don't mean but I want people that
I don't want people to think that
because you coming from a good place you
mean well I think ela sometimes comes
off a little harsher than she intends
yeah
when and and and that's the Israeli side
of her possibly you know her heart she's
she's pure of heart and sweet of heart
and what she's trying to say is that she
wants me to be happy and healthy and I
think what she know what she knows more
is that it makes me miserable being fat
and yeah making I see yourself I see you
like you know not being able to wear
what you want or being uncomfortable
yeah it's awful my thighs rub together
my armpits starting to rub together cuz
I'm so fat I can't breathe when I tie my
shoes
I was feeling that stuff in the ninth
month of being pregnant so I ordered a
also the acid reflux gets worse and it's
it's really uncomfortable the worst part
about being fat for me is the thigh
rubbing like right under my nuts on my
thighs there's no hair left from the
friction but it's just I have to I have
to shove my boxers in between my my legs
no what do you call that area between
the hospital and the balls taint the
taint the huge ya taint couch I shove my
underwear in my Gooch to prevent the
chafing like this I'll show you guys
yeah you have to but so you have to
shove the underwear but not the pants so
looks normal cuz if you do like this so
I mastered attention wear the underwear
so that's my life and you're absolutely
right you and I know all that
exactly ela she's right Sheila's right
and she's frustrated that watch me make
these bad decisions time and time again
it's fine if you guys want to hate me go
ahead I'm okay with it
oh I can understand it it's fine
no no it's not fun sometimes I think
also like May I don't know maybe I
shouldn't enable you you know cuz it is
an addiction but I don't it's so tough
like well I don't know he's holding it
up to me yes not if you're not enabling
me I'm very insistent and when I get an
idea in my head I want to you know do
something me something bad I mean it's
not your place
ultimately it has to come from within me
that change and so yeah you're in a
tough place you say do I have to I say
something do I help him or just be quiet
because often you'll say something and
it'll come off like you're being mean or
judgmental and it's like ultimately what
can you do is just you know it's my it's
my choice yeah so I think you're good I
think your intentions are pure I think
you're loving wonderful wife I
and change you I mean I wouldn't change
anything about you ever when I change a
single thing about you I wouldn't change
anything about you except my way no it's
fine look it's fine
I am personally not into like super
muscley look and you know skinny I don't
want you to go that rock so I want
there's nothing more I wanted them to
lose weight but here's what I do I'm
gonna eat these burger and fries
then I'm gonna go home and I'm knocking
anything really I maybe have some
watermelon all right
go sit on I'm I'm below and I'm bit and
I'm gonna do my steps - mm-hmm
I've been getting in 6,000 steps a day
and I walk in the house it's the
weirdest thing shredder watches me like
I'm crazy but I do step today I want to
go outside hot [ __ ] awful but their
neighborhoods kind of shady - at night
so I just stay in and walk around the
house so where would you rate this I'm
the best episodes ever
I totally poop the whole episode you
didn't poop it I wouldn't you just thing
about you you not even not even a
content I have to give some context to
that comment I had a friend once he had
me proofreading a paper for his college
exam and he used the word
and he said instead of hair I was a hair
from whatever he said I was a [ __ ] hair
away and I was like bro why did you
write [ __ ] hair and he's like what do
you mean that's like common language
cut hair dude vulgar as hell and I don't
I don't know why he just wrote in [ __ ]
hair and he thought it was totally fine
but I just that stuck with him just
popped in my head there because from The
Sopranos huh but he just wrote in
Conterra in his college essay
I was just blowing away never I actually
had never even heard the phrase [ __ ]
hair yeah so I wouldn't change not even
a con Here I am thank you just you know
to bring it down all the way
all right let's move on come we got to
manage to eat we got some burgers to eat
Kanye's got a cult oh my god how dare it
is he built the domes based on Star Wars
now he and what's cult-like about it cuz
you were the one that said it's cold
like uh sorry my my brains a little that
I was drawn in that conversation there
the Mayo is here by the way update it's
here already yeah yeah China outpost
mate
Wow the jar is looking pretty good
cults err what is over piping in this
[ __ ] smell and it's [ __ ] with all
of our head like we're all so hungry
right now why does it smell like burgers
in here there's like some gremlin eating
fast food in the big dogs I smell it I
haven't [ __ ] on a chick-fil-a and
Popeyes in here two days ago it might
it's it's just like in the carpet now
dude there's no that's so that is it so
in the trash or something no trash has
been emptied yeah I don't know man it's
the Wiener schnitzels smells in our car
so sweet
I was blown away it was like onions I
honestly just want to watch that eat
some mayonnaise and then I want to eat
how long's it we didn't even really want
to see that they are we didn't talk
about any of the main stories so let's
just do that oh my god Pro Jared okay
let's just talk about it we have to we
have to doing well how how also in the
thumbnail in title and they just never
get to it most people wouldn't even
realize okay what do we call this video
like literally try to title this video
yeah Eli James Ethan
ela fetching you're not gonna like her
after this I promise nobody you're right
I mean no day I preempted because people
are gonna say that they're gonna say
that but say that I'm telling everybody
know anybody that gets mad had a wife
wanting her husband to just be healthy
[ __ ] off with that what the hell don't
get mad at you look OH
dan you're too green let's talk about
projared let's just get it I have
obligations here okay
Pro Jared finally responds now how
long's it been since the pro jared
controversy happened it's been a lot on
me so yeah funny that one one of his
main go me June July August 3-4 months
find it funny he goes not one person
reached out to me not one person and he
showed a picture of us our podcast
amongst others to talk to them yeah but
I'm like dude you didn't speak you is if
you were to put out a statement I would
have covered it you didn't say anything
yeah I don't know you I'm not gonna
reach out to you I didn't reach out to
anyone else I don't understand that
whole logic of needing to reach out to
anyone not a journalist this is not in
the New York Times up some [ __ ] dude
who's about to watch my employee eat a
jar of mayonnaise what research do you
expect me to do exactly
we talked about all kinds of stuff are
we gonna reach out to everyone together
[Music]
yeah anyway so here first of all I got
an email from a pro Jared fan there's
what tipped me off that he responded he
says he says you will openly apologize
for spreading misinformation against
Jared connect Abeka
the show does email yeah [ __ ] this guy
all right
mod next sucks at gmail.com I mean it's
just email what can you do no you will
openly apologize for spreading
misinformation against Jared neighbor
balbirr where you learn suffering as he
has and worse
and worse and hurts fans are crazy I was
like dude I know I Jared sent me this
email didn't he so okay what
misinformation that I spread about Jared
I think not I was reporting what
happened talking about how crazy it was
how the kickback I had never seen
anything like that losing 25% of your
fan base in a day or whatever now he
spends the majority of his video
responding to allegations that these two
dudes said that he solicited nudes from
them underage I well I went back and
watched our coverage of that story week
a loss over that only the last three
minutes of the 20 minute segment and we
we say that it's uncorroborated and
frankly that was to me was never the
most interesting part of the story
because obviously anyone can make up and
say anything they want on Twitter he
spends the most of his time saying I did
not solicit nudes from these people and
I asked them if they were 18 so I think
he goes he goes I he basically shows
that they were lying about him doing
that so okay fine
he does however openly admit to to
getting nudes from his fans you know
remember sing Jared the secret tumblr
syn Jared hmm so let's see I've got um
got a lot time-stamped here so to me
let the see it listen miss something
that's important to note he managed to
look like as pathetic as possible and as
crazy as possible in the video and my to
my surprise people really responding to
this video he's getting his subs back
lots of likes and people are responding
but I think he kind of pulled a fast one
on everyone I'm gonna be totally honest
I'm gonna keep it 100 I think the guys
is total sceles
should not have a fan base because while
he
refutes the worst claims of these two
individuals
he admits slyly at the same time that he
was soliciting nudes from his fans who
watches his videos young people it's a
video game channel yes most of the
audience for those channels are on the
younger side exactly they're not like in
their thirties that's for sure he goes
you know he admits to getting nudes from
his fans
I mean I'm gonna show you all the
evidence but he doesn't he barely dude
you can't if you're eight and if you
have a community if you're famous
you cannot put yourself in a position to
be getting nudes from fit especially
young fans he goes all he all he shows
to prove that he asked he goes real
quick are you 18 plus they're 16 year
old of course they'll say yes that's why
you don't put yourself in that position
to begin with and by the way I know he
just said that the covers asked in case
something like this happened what she
half expected yeah you know if you if
you [ __ ] someone under the age of 18 and
and they lied about their age guess
who's still going to jail that's why you
don't [ __ ] that's why you don't do this
oh why do you think people want to send
you their nudes because you're handsome
no it's because they know who you are
that's the only reason people want to
send you their news dude and trust me
it's you may be the most handsome I mean
I mean you know we'll get a look at that
face I'm shocked the people are buying
this this guy is a sleaze dude he's yes
sex Jared Sen Jared yet a form called
sin charrid where he accepted and he
does it under the guise he goes oh I'm
just I'm doing it as sex positive mm-hm
just expressing this bro that's not sex
positive that's creepy is maybe if it
was anonymous exactly one we're
anonymous and X that and they didn't
know that you were Jared and nags
or whatever it is I don't know what it
is some blog I think it's disgusting I
think he totally is manipulative because
he's like well I just proved this and
I'm gonna kind of underhandedly admit to
doing this but this isn't as bad as that
it is I never cared about this whole
thing with these random stories on
Twitter because I know that [ __ ] can be
made up the fact that you are in the
position of getting nudes from your fans
is so such an abuse of power it's so
disgusting it's so creepy that you are
not responsible to handle having a
community of young people I mean you're
betting to me that's like stay-stay a
hundred feet away from schools dude like
what do you do I mean this guy should
not have a community he's not
responsible this is so gross and by the
way bro I have seen your deck there
should not be pictures of your dick out
there don't put yourself in the position
of that he put himself in the position
to be able to be accused of the things
that they accused him if he wasn't on
there with all this sin shared and all
this [ __ ] these accusations wouldn't
hold any water mm-hmm but you created an
environment where that shit's believable
dude I don't buy it
this guy he's you know and he tries to
make a big thing about canceled culture
and all this bro
you were there's a difference we cancel
culture for someone saying an offensive
joke and someone abusing the power and
getting nudes from underage fans
you cannot conflate the difference there
yeah this guy actually totally agree on
that point cuz we were just talking
about castle culture on the last episode
but this is not exactly like you said
this is not accusing him of making a bad
joke that is not PC you know and by the
way if he's on there soliciting nudes
you know that a large portion of them
are gonna be underage people regardless
if he said oh are you eighteen plus just
checking we're in the same position we
have a channel I think our audience is
probably older than he is absolutely and
even us if I ask someone if I was in
this position I would totally expect
that that there's gonna be at least 50%
of them under 18 of course
come on is your brain bro you tell me
that is not a gets stopped on the street
we know exactly what age our fans are we
see them on the street when they say hi
we see in meet and greets it's not like
a mystery he knows exactly what kind of
fans his are much younger than they are
definitely younger than so it's you it's
impossible to conclude that he didn't
know as a possibility that those nudes
were gonna be minors even though he's
like oh real check we're a family you're
18 plus I'll show you all that but I
also imagined this that I'm on a forum
people know who I am I'm talking to a
girl and I'm and I'm creating the
environment where she can send me nudes
and I want to see her news that is so
creepy and perverts dude that's so
creepy and weird and perverse and then
to create a forum dedicated to it sin
Jared bro you cannot live down sin Jared
change your name to sin Jared because I
don't think you get to live that one
down and on top of it on top of it all
you look like earthworm jim and i am
gonna make fun of his looks because i
think what he did is creepy it's fine if
you want to make fun of his look but i
think that is unrelated dude and i
wouldn't want that to disqualify
everything else we said so whatever
that's just silly that's one thing but
then nodes are not that silly it's my
point you're right I shouldn't have made
the earthworm jim yeah I've seen the
man's penis I have to unfortunately and
frankly freaking dude it I mean it's
fine but it's not special not good
enough to be sending pic people like
it's not even like a hog it's not like a
particularly beautiful like a normal
dick like you don't get to give a normal
dick you don't get to send dick pics
they'd better be spectacular you're
sending dick pics
right
anyway let's watch this the way chai and
Charlie made their statements they use a
logical fallacy known as poisoning the
well it's a tactic in which before you
are presented with information you are
given subtext opinions or other
irrelevant information to negatively
affect your opinion about something oh
and Jerry or you find out he thinks
something is in other words to
manipulate you and it worked on
everybody Charlie's a qs8 so I mean he
goes on about logical fallacies but I I
think first of all I think he's the one
doing logical fallacies here we either
had to look it up how about the ill
irrelevant conclusion a fallacy of
presenting an argument that may or may
not be logically valid and sound but
whose conclusion fails to address the
issue and question the issue in question
for me the one that really mattered that
we spend all of our time talking about
is was he exchanging nudes with his fans
and the answer he admits to is yes here
he is admitting to it what this all came
down to was people saying that I was
exchanging nudes with fans on snapchat
and Tumblr and a lot of people want to
know if I did any of that
yeah I did and I always made it clear
that it was for consenting adults only
this came about when numerous people had
asked me about it and wanted to know if
it was okay to do let me let me look at
listen this is a message you got I'm not
drunk as [ __ ] yet but I will told you
totally send you Ted pics
I said yes that it would be a safe place
for people who wish to express
themselves in that way and for me to
express myself in that way it was an
open invitation for those who wanted to
do it and that I wouldn't be offended or
upset and that nothing would be shared
or saved without explicit permission to
be clear it was an open invitation to
those who wanted bro you cannot do that
yeah an open invitation hey guys send me
your news send me your nudes but just
say it's in place but I'm not gonna
check anything further than that just
good if I tweet it out right now hey
send me your nudes 18-plus only guys I'm
gonna get 50% of kids sending me their
[ __ ] prepubescent [ __ ] and by the way
dude I'm sure you saw some questionable
[ __ ] they should have made you think I
should not be doing this and I'm sure
that he's doing this just for you know
posterity sick just to have said it so
in case this happened you gonna be like
18 plus guys to participate the choice
was always up to them
at no point did I ever go through my
followers list and single out
individuals or screams he doesn't go to
jail and he knows that's illegal I never
did that I always left the choice up to
them let them choose is what he said by
the way how do you feel about your
husband's obsession with nudes okay he's
got an obsession do you see this there's
a question people know that he's
obsessed with nudes on his tumblr engage
this question all the time do you see
how for most this isn't it's live I get
this quite and this is just the
shittiest showing proof the proof is
what nothing I know but what she's
saying what he's saying that she's
getting it so I shall this time it's
happening all the time
the fact that I get this question all
the time tells me that people expect me
to be upset about it
jerk impose whatever he wants on his
tumblr he's not hurting the one he's not
cheating on money
he's just whatever whatever and he says
I love you wife send nudes but do you
see what I'm my point is Dan now's a
good time for the devil advocate samba
I don't even think this but just to play
devil's advocate for a second um my
point is is that in this community
everybody knows he's obsessed with nudes
he wants to receive nudes at the open
invite
also this whole thing of saying that
it's what they want they want to send
like Newton blaming it's so manipulative
it's bad it's something that our Kelly
would say yeah the girls who want to be
here right they love me having to take
the phone away that's what they want
it's like no no this is not normal you
want you create this environment yes
they're your fans they're route they
want to please you they want your
attention you've made it clear that you
like newts and you're okay and if you
want maybe take off your shirt you know
if you want my attention and your fan
there's a way that you can do it they'll
say you know what I mean no heat if I'm
gonna tell Dan and Ian hey guys you want
to take off your clothes or whatever
it's like yet to you I'm phrasing it
like they want it but I'm suggesting it
I'm creating this environment he goes
well you guys want to take off your
clothes I mean only if you want to and
if you're 18 plus and consenting
obviously do something right but like if
you want to take your clothes off I'm
always here and there's open invitation
but anyway I'm not gonna talk to you
I've so if you want to talk and that's a
good way to start a conversation with me
18 plus conscious effort to treat
everyone with this same respect always
and I see no shame what goes on between
consenting adults it was never meant to
be an abuse of power I never offered
anyone anything in return like making
them a twitch mod or early access to a
youtube video or whatever
such a full record I never gave them
anything what you're offering that was
your attention they're your fans bro
he's he's acting like you're not that
dense you know what you did is [ __ ] up
stop he's always saying like I never
paid anyone yeah or in
threaten anyone I never blackmailed
anyone I never hidden his mines like I
never course to anyone I just had an
open invitation everybody knows I'm
obsessed with nudes they asked my wife
all the time bro you're a creep you are
such a creep how did this apology I feel
like in my opinion this apology made me
think even less of him mm-hmm that's how
I felt but yet people are people are
saying he pulled the ultimate uno card
or whatever just because he was so
focused on disproving those two kids I
think that he that that's the logical
fallacy he just proved them but by
disproving them he'd make over exactly
he he he focused on something much much
worse and then by doing so tried to
negate the actual issue at hand but but
the stuff he said in here actually
incriminates him even more I also never
threatened anyone any kind of punishment
if they did it that's in his mind like
that that's that's in his mind you has
to be that explicit I didn't threaten
anyone I did it punishes anyone I didn't
blackmail anybody I didn't promise them
early access yeah that's not how it
works bro people are gonna send you
their tits for early accident they do it
for your attention you dense
[ __ ] predator I'm gonna call him a
predator you are accepting fans from
your nudes you sick [ __ ] and they're
underage shame on you Jared you
earthworm jim looking [ __ ] when you
crawl back under the ground where you
belong I'm pissed this is disgusting
this guy shouldn't be on this platform
it's horrific I'm angry about it he
should not be forgiven dude and by
definition he shouldn't because he's
admitting in this video he's saying I
did nothing wrong
it's consenting adults I'm obsessed with
nudes it's an open where I'm sex
positive which means I've done nothing
wrong and you all acknowledge that so
let's just keep accepting nudes maybe
that's my problem more than anything is
that it seems to complete and get the
problem I think he's just brushing over
a domain issue and yeah me not to hear
it gets it's however I want to
knowledge now that there was a power in
bears only thought about it now that
comes down to who I am and what I do why
the [ __ ] do you think they're sending
you nudes to begin with if you were just
some random creep on Craigslist
nobody would send you anything you would
not have people lining up around the
block to send you their nudes just make
an anonymous thing then why send send
Jared you're I mean dude come on you
know it was apparently love nothing
offered and returned there was still
incentive for people to do it because
yeah I am a youtuber yes it doesn't
matter this just yes like it has just
occurred am neutral the intent was just
being in this position
what's neutral about what's neutral I
just neutrally want your news despite I
don't care I'm not sure yeah
causes a power imbalance and a lot of
people saw that and were upset at me for
that reason and to those of you who feel
that way
I completely understand how you feel and
why you feel that way
and I'm sorry I feel something so you
[ __ ] off about that apology there's
something about the fact that he says I
understand how you feel and what you
feel that way I don't feel that way yeah
but you chose to be offended by it and
understand why you feel that way why do
you know what I mean it's like why is he
apologizing to me I don't know it's very
weird he's like yeah I abused my power
I'm sorry to you who felt that way just
seems like he's not really understanding
that what he did is wrong yeah it's just
the feeling that I got but this whole
this whole shtick like he just now
realized that it's an abuse of power
it's just it's it's slow disingenuous
it's so manipulative this whole thing I
don't know all that just
be right what I was doing I was hot so
strata Tori I think it was but it was
unhealthy okay you abuse your power you
had met there was a power imbalance yet
it wasn't predatory how do you explain
that that's what this hold me two things
about is that these powerful men or men
are using their their their influence
you just don't put yourself in that
position dude I don't know what to tell
you man go get a [ __ ] date I don't
know go I don't know man don't accept
nudes from fans when you have a young
audience too so what is [ __ ] what is
this shirt he's wearing - can we talk
about that but that isn't the main
grievance that everyone has with me it
is it is it is exact that it is so
that's so we brushed over that he's like
well anyway that's not really a big deal
I apologize for that
and whatever it wasn't a predatory yes
it was but anyway nobody really cares
about that here's what they really care
about didn't spy these two he goes on he
spends the entire video disproving there
which again don't care about that and
then at the end he says about the
divorce it's none of your business
that's fine mm-hmm I agree it's none of
my business it's fine that is disproving
those two I it's not cool for people to
make up stuff obviously oh yes those
kids I mean I don't want to make it seem
like that part is not [ __ ] up trying
fun well he did he fully disproves one
the other he doesn't really disprove all
he pretends that they lied about clearly
age I honestly don't even need to go
into it because I don't care about it
it's all disputable as he said she said
right what is not disputable that he
openly admits to is that he's [ __ ]
accepting nudes from his young fan base
that's indisputably creepy and
disgusting you can't do that like if
that alone was leaked that would be
career-ending but he's he's positioned
it neck
to these other claims yeah and now all
the sudden everybody's forgiving him
here access to all of our messages and
saw the truth this does bring up the
question why didn't I ask for people's
IDs and the answer is because that would
be asking people to Doc's themselves
which seems when you're in the position
to ask for people's IDs you already lost
about now you already lost problem far
more risky besides there's no way what's
raised can verify IDs then defend an ID
he's like listen I couldn't even verify
it if they send it to me how about they
black out the pertinent information how
about you asking as well there's no way
for you to verify when they say yes or
no to your real quick are you item plus
here they saw it was them who continued
to initiate conversations with me on the
proper single part of Charlie's
allegations against me hinges on the
belief that I didn't know their age and
or didn't ask
they even argued that I should have
known their age because they used the
phrase I am a baby as if this somehow
denotes how old they generally are even
though it's using a context of shyness
listen look at this conversation by the
way I got invited to a gangbang by five
other people she told Jared or he I
don't know Jared says oh he blurts
something out yep was their name okay
explain to girl oh wait no I'm confused
so that's what she or he is feeling
intimidated he blacked out their name so
he removed this but I remember seeing
the whole thing how old
they generally are he's all like jerking
off until you say yes dated and I the
whole conversation is like he it's so
disgusting
so did you I think it was part of the
original leak where he's like I'm
jerking off to your nudes right now or
something creepy like that it's not sex
positive he's getting himself off he is
jerking off he's gratifying himself
sexually
this isn't like just trying to make feel
make people feel good about themselves
he is gratifying himself sexually I did
ask their age why'd they a lot they lied
they're 16 dude and second of all this
isn't exactly due diligence no real
quick like an afterthought Oh real quick
heck I have a ton of news but I usually
don't send them to people he said has to
be certain yeah I do I'm certain off of
yes yeah real quick real quick are you
18 plus yeah of course okay thank God he
didn't even ask or what is your age what
is your age how old are you right are
you 18 plus real quick can I see your ID
block out the pertinent information well
I couldn't even prove it if they did
well it's better than this or the
ultimate uh the ultimate preventer do
you know what it is ela mm-hmm
don't solicit nudes from your fans
underage fans but fans in general you
creepy [ __ ] and you know he's beating
off during this conversation and I've
seen his penis too and it's nothing
spectacular I'm gonna to repeat that
they also clearly knew then that they
were doing something they know they
shouldn't and is doing something teen
bro you created environment sounds like
he you and knew you were doing something
you shouldn't you're talking to a 16
year old you [ __ ] creep you beat off
to a 16 year olds nudes and it's their
fault but he beat off to his 16 year
olds nudes and it's their fault for
lying to him guys am I the only one the
writing on the wall it's guys a [ __ ]
creep oh I'm not okay with they had full
access to the entire conversation
and omitted to all of you that they lied
to me
deceiving all of you they knew about
this from the get-go which is why on
Twitter they immediately began to
backpedal on their claims changing their
tone from claiming I didn't say he knew
my age I said he was predatory predatory
behavior would be targeting an
individual and pursuing after them often
repeatedly you don't need the band as
Charlie had an accident worry I know a
predatory is it's at this conversation
you created an environment it's not
predatory like the Church of Scientology
but we're not predatory we just wait for
someone to walk into our building that
would suck him for life right we're not
predatory he walked in of his own free
will shut up Jerry you creepy [ __ ] God
our whole conversation they saw it was
them who continued to initiate
conversations with me unprompted
numerous times four months along you
know what that you call that a power
imbalance why do you think they're
pursuing you because you're so desirable
they just go out there for months
cuz they're your fans you and then it
just does them a favor and accepts the
nudes can I send you more stuff no see
it was that guy is a saint they wanted
it he didn't do anything
meanwhile backtrack five five minutes
tell me more about your threesome did
you do it uh I don't care can i friend
out of your nudes but Charlie chose to
admit that and when they spoke with The
Daily Beast
they lied it's not about what was
emitted bro it's about what you're
plainly admitting to right now what else
we got
yeah that's it in summary typing 18-plus
does not make you not liable
you are an adult celebrity that is a
creating environment on sin Jared
piggybacking off your identity mm-hmm so
they know fel will fall well who there
whose attention they're getting you know
oh that's me I mean if you have sex with
an underage girl guess what if they lie
to you you still had sex with underage
girl you're trying to act like you
you've never thought about what a power
dynamic is yet you called your secret
tumblr sin Jared using your online
persona to get nude nobody wants to send
you their nudes they only want to do it
cuz they know cuz they want your
attention he says the entire time trying
to dispute the account of these two
people on Twitter whose accounts were a
questionable B to get to begin with but
the fact that he's soliciting nudes from
his young audience which is the grossest
part for me he glosses over and acts
like nobody cares about it I mean
ultimately I think this guy doesn't
deserve that vote I think he's a I think
he's a danger to his audience and I've
seen his cut I've seen his dick I mean
good once I've seen you take you're done
you've got pics of your dick how many
people you send your pic of your picture
of your dick to before it gets on the
internet right yeah some to that
weird I mean it's one of the things I've
seen yeah
imagine if I went and set up a tumblr
called uh I mean the send part is so
full of nothing is worse than yeah
imagine and why do you think Ethan's
heathens that's not even as bad Sen
Ethan anyway that's all I have to say
about that finally was talk about
Chappell and unless he is a food here
the food did just arrived yes how long
we've been going how are 45 this
shitpile thing's gonna take a minute to
get through mmm cliff notes by the way
wasn't there like a a news story there's
this youtuber that I never heard of
Austin Jones mmm that was guilty of
soliciting nerds yeah I recall something
like that but I'm sure if the FBI goes
and collects his hard drives if he
hasn't microwave them already
they're gonna find tons of underage
nudies that other guy was persuading
underage fans to send him graphic videos
so I guess and maybe the difference is
that Jared covered himself by asking are
you 18 plus real quick I don't think
that covers him I think he hasn't been
investigated I don't know what's the
severity difference I don't I don't know
how forceful this guy was being right in
a way if there's enough to like charge
him with something or not I think it's
creepy and it's not right so
unresponsible it's not really one who
has fence um let's see Dave Chappelle's
new special got on a lot of controversy
which is funny because he pretty much is
baiting everybody and when I watched
this new one it was great I loved it and
I was thinking to myself there is no way
that people are gonna take the bait
again because he's very self-aware and I
felt like watching
he just thought of the most offensive
things he could talk about possible and
and tried to make it make it you know
tall funny which i think is a pretty
admirable goal he talked about trans
people he talked about louis c.k michael
jackson he talked about rape i mean he
went every single place he could and
tried to make it funny which is a really
cool yet still you see headlines i saw
this from vice they go
you can definitely skip Dave Chappelle's
new Netflix special i watch the whole
thing there those articles are so
douchey
I think they just clicked it like you
can definitely escape and who are you
exactly
well because they say that he continues
to laugh at the hardship of trans people
that doesn't mean it's not funny I saw
articles that are even saying that it's
not funny which I find just like well
that that's just that's just erroneous
yeah it's funny
Dave still one of the funniest comedians
ever I mean there's no question about it
do you think everyone's just watching it
to piss off trans people right watching
cuz it's funny I recommend it I thought
was great there was there was a couple
of jokes in there he said to piss people
off there was the trans jokes which she
kind of doubled down on
he's like the trans hate me because I
guess he said a lot of trans jokes in
the back and he he kind of doubled down
but I don't think he really I mean I
don't think you really said anything
unforgiveable or even provocative I
don't think he was trying to poke them
he told this he told this anecdote about
a trans person at a show and I think it
was a I thought it was a pretty good
point he says this trans person said to
me it's funny they give you [ __ ] for for
making jokes about are Kelly and you
made him mainstream and acceptable yet
you do the same thing about trans people
and instead of saying you making them
mainstream and acceptable they say the
you're discriminating against them
I thought that was pretty interesting
then there's the other one he says about
louis c.k jerking off in front of people
he thought it wasn't a big deal again
it's like you gotta watch it get the
watch it don't it's a piece of art I
mean he's he's like yes this is writing
like jokes on that is like the top of
the top of comedians right his his
specials are pieces of art like
seriously they're amazing and it's all
very thought thoughtful and there's a
lot there's like storyline to the whole
thing and the jokes are great and I just
think it's so funny that some guy on
Vice is gonna call it like oh you can
skip that right let's let's see your
next special mister whoever you're
exactly he did this bit about Michael
Jax and he was saying he thinks they're
lying I'm someone that is strongly
believes that Michael Jackson right I
mean to add a file yet I I was able to
watch that bit and I saw what he was
doing he was trying to make he was
trying to make a bit about something as
controversial as Michael Jackson and all
those allegations and just make a funny
commentary about make a funny show about
the most like horrible topic that you
could think of yeah because he goes on
one hand those I think they're lying but
on the other hand he goes if I was
molested by Michael Jackson he's Michael
Jackson it's still Michael Jackson you
know so it's like he opens the door for
it he did it he didn't do it but it's
all I'm making it funny
that's his objective is to be
entertaining and not to be insulting he
even jokes about school shootings which
was very funny that it's a white
people's game which I totally agree
because I never once thought about I'm
gonna kill everybody in my school he had
some oh this one joke this one joke
about rape he got a ton of [ __ ] for it
but it's so funny he's saying I'm at my
show and I make a joke about rape I
don't member what it was
and a woman stands up crying she goes I
was raped and she's making a big scene
she's storming out and Dave goes ma'am
it's not my fault
it's not your fault you were raped but
it's not my fault either Tata [ __ ] you
know what can you do it's funny you go
well obviously you gotta watch this show
I'm just you're gonna watch it and I
think it's just so dumb that we're even
having to defend some like it's it's all
a common debate can we put it in
perspective well it's funny it's not
writing a manifesto no the funny thing
is is that he completely created
he gave them debate he really baited
them because I think first of all it
just helps him when people start talking
about how offensive it is and it's
really not and he's kind of just
lampooning now at this point just how
obscenely predictable these people are
right I swear to God I was like they're
not gonna take them but sure enough it's
like the core the choir of offender
balls come in at the perfect moment and
I think he really just goofed on them
all because it's really not that
offensive and he just played them for
the free PR and really just a commentary
on them so I highly recommend Dave
Chappelle
by the way it's called sticks and stones
sticks and stones may break my bones but
words will never hurt me that's what
it's from which is what parents tell
kids and they go to school like hey yeah
words are just worse they can't hurt you
yeah and so once again he's saying hey
guys just sticks and tones nope anyway
let's get back in here let's let's get
the mayonnaise going Zach come here we
got $500 on the line as he's setting up
I've got one more if you don't want to
show you right we got the are we set up
here down so as we get ready I want to
show you this new Joe Biden
brain-melting
wait you want to do it out here no in
here in there yeah okay we'll bring it
in so Joe Biden couldn't remember
Obama's name and when I saw this I was
like
listen that because they invaded another
country do you present my advice senile
president my mother that come here right
here okay Zack so we've got five hundred
dollars on the line you got to finish
the whole jar how many calories are in
that so one two so well there's six
hundreds are 60 servings and it's a
hundred ten calories per serving so do
the math on that six thousand thousand
I'm more worried about the carbs in that
there's not a lot of carbs so it's
called keto so you're good I'm good at
six thousand calories I'm all good I'm
rockin oh wow okay so so what we're
doing here is the Mayo challenge where
we have five hundred dollars on the line
if you can finish it
do you think you'll be able to finish it
I'm I'm going in I'm just gonna look at
the cover of this you're gonna pretend
you're eating that yeah so I think
you're gonna get like five bites I think
you might even just get two if I'm being
honest if I do this I won't take your
money doing this for the show no I'm
gonna pay you I won't give you the you
earn it man yes there we go
how's it smell take a smell is this the
good stuff is this the mayonnaise of
choice the regulars from you are the
real man oh you got the oh he got us to
Kroger [ __ ] you guys the store brand all
right so Cheers
there we go you definitely getting the
500 if you finished that bro oh my
goodness
wow wow he's in two three bites Wow
he's slowing down he's thinking about it
twice now can I have water with this No
the waters will slow it down too much
I'm afraid
you're actually doing really good yeah
I'm impressed that's impressive for full
go ahead take your time mm-hmm four huge
spoons man it's gonna make you [ __ ]
wait I think yeah three no well whatever
he's got a head I don't want to get to
shoot my hair yeah I don't want mailing
your hair either oh my goodness yeah I'm
doing good I'm impressed
Oh left in there yeah you're all you
still have like 3/4 left
I think you can do it though I know war
but not not I don't want it to slow it
down too much
no I also don't okay you get what you
get once five bites once it a little
sippy okay there you go okay keep it
going this is how is it rate against
horsey sauce better than horsey sauce
you want to cut to our backup plan
is there any chance you might few case
of a gag nah I don't know if we can show
them vomiting we'll probably get the
good eating it like [ __ ] cereal my
dude oh yeah yeah
walk me through this how does it taste
how does it feel doing okay right now
would gag it's a little bit nauseous
she gagged ooh she did she did I feel
like for Bob I don't think I can do any
more how much did we get let me see
we're like halfway like I mean that's
half I have to tell you I'm long
impressed
I'm impressed oh my god you might be
able to do again if you're actually
striving now what I'd like to know are
you are you tapping out
I appreciate that headline report back
when you have a dump later I want to
know about that you want pictures no
nothing but I want to know how you're
feeling okay you know I mean it did half
man if two packs of horsey sauce gets
you yeah but who knows what's in that
you know I've never done that before
that was gnarly
well this this is this is good
entertainment folks is what we do here
Cheers look at the H Lake podcast to
Zack that Garelick stop
well it's TGIF cheers if anyone's got a
bud bucket of mayonnaise that home
thanks doc we've got some Veggie girl
backstage and I'm dying to get to you're
gonna be fine like you're sorry I'm okay
I mean I want to keep going I could try
I could drive it I got it I think I need
some more water
see this boil water dog yeah what about
water messes it up if you have a second
one you can keep trying but I it's got
it you gotta commit now do I get 250 for
finishing half no I made it very clear
to use that okay I said 500 or nothing
[ __ ] you guys call it take another buy
it
dude it you have all the time you need
if you have a sec but you got the veggie
grill out there I don't wanna like miss
hey we're here for dinner I know we're
enjoying yeah we're here to entertain
but but I would say hurt you unless you
think you can finish it I don't want you
to punish yourself for nothing no I
can't okay I'm not having do it okay I'm
tapping out I'm sorry I failed you
honestly I didn't think you would make
it through like half of that oh you
wanna guess you want to know I can't
even are you Alex come on your sandwich
sure you up with someone - I love man no
I still you know there we go he's gone
him for another bite
the texturize would be awful not loving
that well that's all we have for you
guys today we Came we saw we ate
mayonnaise we slammed what more is there
to doing it episode don't know
have a great Friday congratulations to
Zack we need him like munching on me or
something like just wanting something I
do I'm gonna get up
thanks for watching all this man is
everybody hungry see you next week
[Music]